the video game industry has never been
more innovative or exciting but with so
many great games coming out it's
inevitable that some games would just
slip through the cracks here's a look at
some incredible games no one bought
vampire the masquerade bloodlines hardly
anyone bought vampire the masquerade
bloodlines when it came out over a
decade ago vampires weren't yet
sparkling and the kind of vampires
bloodlines del worth were no longer that
popular but those are did buy the game
are not only still playing it but
creating their own new content for it
that's the kind of passion this hybrid
RPG inspires in its fans of its
immersive story of a vampire who must
negotiate a world of undead clans
competing for supremacy it remains a
great treat for retro gamers but be
careful even now the hotel level is
scary enough to cause my mess so play at
your own risk Panzer Dragoon saga after
to traditional rail shooters the Panzer
Dragoon franchise took an unexpected
detour into the realm of Final Fantasy
style RPGs with this classic 1998
release Panzer Dragoon saga has been
acclaimed as one of the greatest RPGs of
all time
so why didn't anyone buy it well I had
the misfortune of being released for the
Sega Saturn in 1998 the same year the
platform was discontinued in North
America talk about bad timing
psyops the mind gate conspiracy in this
one endured adventure from 2004 for the
Xbox and ps2 players assume control of
an amnesiac of psychic powers and the
nefarious paramilitary group on his tail
it may not sound particularly innovative
now but that's because dozens of games
have since copied its mind-bending
telekinetic gameplay sadly fans of the
game never got a sequel and likely never
will as the studio behind psyops closed
in 2010 deadly premonition lots of games
get mixed reviews but Delly premonition
actually earned the guinness world
record for being the most critically
polarizing survival horror game taking
many cues from Twin Peaks and Japanese
horror Deadly Premonition is a must
played title for fans of B movies and
anyone wanting a bizarre left-field
experience you have to buy gas for your
car without coffee you'll get sleepy on
top of this the graphics aren't even
great for 2010 and the combat system is
terrible in other words it's not for
everyone but if you don't hate it
chances are you're gonna love it
with Deadly Premonition there's really
no middle ground Viking battle for
Asgard there's something to be said for
a game of mindless destruction spent
mowing down enemies like weeds sure it
might not break new ground but if you
want to break some skills instead this
is your game lost in the shuffle among
more hyped and more innovative titles
Viking battle for Asgard just as one
simple thing but it does it very very
well indeed The Saboteur the final game
from developer pandemic studios The
Saboteur is the open-world game set
during world war two sort of like Grand
Theft Auto in german-occupied France
with noir inspired graphics and an
unusual story based style that sees you
inspiring rebellion against the Nazi
overlords The Saboteur feels about as
far from cookie-cutter world war ii
shooters as possible and that's a good
thing
vanquish running gun duck and cover
punched Giants in the face it's not just
the mantra of this fast-paced
third-person shooter it's also a motto
for life vanquish doesn't necessarily do
anything new but it does everything well
with the controls and graphics all
top-notch for a last generation actioner
fans at the time thought it looked too
derivative of games like Bayonetta but
sometimes fun Trump's innovation this is
one of those times brutal legend
designer Tim Schafer previously brought
gamers idiosyncratic titles like
Psychonauts and Grim Fandango and this
is no exception a rock and roll Love
Letter featuring the likes of Ozzy
Osbourne and Lemmy Kilmister from
Motorhead among its voice cast brutal
legend find your roadie player character
and their party roaming across a heavy
metal hellscape securing territory
through real-time combat and strategy
the game while a poor seller was praised
for his wit and charm check it out and
rock on bro singularity singularity is a
first-person shooter with a heady time
manipulation mechanic that allows you to
travel forward and backwards through
time affecting gunplay and the
convoluted plot accused of being a
Bioshock knockoff when it was released
this entertaining romp is still worth a
run through for some memorable moments
and my marish monsters and if you can
find some friends to join you for
multiplayer even better thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
you